[Music]  how's my man  oh what no play huh  i really hope you're happy there  i'm working on something to bring you  back  they've never managed to connect a  computer to the archives before  i waited a long time and then i saw  something  we had a visit from the archive company  the subject is elmo julie alice the term  time so far two years eight months four  days  she's not ready to go yet of course they  think your robots might be based around  their technology  we are obliged to act with force if  necessary  you made another like me i'm not  replacing you  but you did it what was she like  she was perfect i want to go home  this is home  jules can you hear me  do not let her outside under any  have to try to get her circumstances i  am shutting you down immediately  what do they want they want you  [Music]  you